[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
segway
when it comes to odds danny sheridan usa
today handicapper
sports analyst last year i figured out
that danny was picking the kansas city
chiefs
i asked him before the super bowl but he
couldn't do it because
he didn't want to release his picks to
uh his clients until game day and i
understand it but
great minds think alike and danny
sheridan joins us you almost lost it but
uh
you did get the win for your clients
danny good to talk to you again
likewise and dan before i forget i want
to congratulate you and the
dazzling danettes on being named by
barrett sports media as the number
two most popular national sports radio
show in the united states
and hopefully next year at this time
they'll name you number one
well thank you danny you know i i would
rather be number three than number
two really yeah yeah
because it's like on monday if you say
to tom brady after he's lost and you go
hey
second best quarterback this weekend i
mean that's
sort of the feeling that i get i i don't
want to be runner up i
i'd rather be third than uh then second
there
okay all right if that makes any sense
all right so you can't tell me who
you're going to take this weekend i
realize that and you've always told me
don't worry about the point spread right
oh no if you just picked the winner you
will have beaten the spread
88 percent of the time 57 percent dan
against the spread is considered
excellent the winner of this game
has beaten the spread 45 times and lost
six
the last team to win the super bowl and
not win
not beat the spread was pittsburgh
against arizona
they won by four in 2009 and i want to
point out that pittsburgh scored with 45
seconds to go to beat arizona but
that was the last time 2009 so just pick
the winner
and again it's not a big spread and you
you have the odds in your favor and
that's what i always try to do just pick
the winner ignore the spread and you
should
you should be right but if you're
picking have you ever picked
the player like i i would never bet
against brady i wouldn't bet
if it meant betting against brady but is
that sound logic at all when you
look at a player and you go i can't bet
against him or i am going to take him
because of that player not that team
well it might be to some people and i
can't disagree it's not to me
aaron rodgers tom brady i was thinking
about green bay and tampa bay i wasn't
thinking i mean
that's important obviously if patrick
mahones didn't play
i would want no part of kansas city but
some people count it
i don't i don't weigh it in my lucky
dope with my dart board
and by the way i give my pick on sunday
i actually make up my mind on sunday for
the total
and for the game and that's when i give
it to my clients one of the reasons
you'd obviously wait till sunday is
on the total is because it could rain in
tampa hopefully it won't
i don't have a theory for if it rains
so you're going to take the over in
kansas city because you're
thinking that it's not going to rain as
much as
what i'm saying is that my in the
article i mentioned
if you have two potent offenses and i'm
going to ask you this question
two potent offenses you go under i know
that sounds contrarian but it happens
that's the way i handicap it
two defensive stalwarts you go over a
good example would be last year
kansas city and san francisco great
offenses they scored
86 and 64 points respectively in their
playoffs
they went under the year before you had
the time
tom brady you had the new england
i'm trying to think it was playing that
it was new england and the rams
yeah two top scoring teams in the
conference the whole year
guess what 13 to three so my question to
you would be
and i will question a bunch of sports
guys and say hey
when you think of kansas city do you
think of offensive defense they'll tell
me offense
i'll accept that so my question to you
dan is when you think of tampa bay
do you think of offense defense are
pretty much
neutral balanced defense
okay then i wouldn't be able to pick the
total if that were the case that's
interesting
and that may be the case if if i find
out or if i make the
when i talk to all these sports writers
if they tell me what you just said
i will not pick the total going in if
it's if they say offense i'm going under
if they say defense and i believe them
i'm going over
paulie what is the weather forecast for
tampa a high of 70 on super bowl sunday
rain for sure in the morning
overcast with rain showers at times high
tide 4 15 p.m
wow does it matter if you jump in
on the line was three and a half and now
i think it's down to three
right it feels like a lot of uh there's
a lot of kansas city money here
but the the instant reaction see that
doesn't factor into you because you said
it
you know just pick who you think is
going to win don't worry about the point
spread
i agree i don't worry about that i just
pick who i think in this case it's
it's safe to say if tampa bay covers
they should win
you're talking three points and and vice
versa obviously if kansas city wins they
they should cover more than three points
and
any other tips that you would give for
people for entertainment purposes only
this sunday
well there's so many then i hope they'll
read the article in usa today
but the key there's so many for example
prop bets people love to bet the coin
flip
will brady throw 5 20 touchdowns 50
passes whatever
will the rushing guy do this bottom line
is if you bet prop bets
which probably in the total handle prop
bets
are more than any other bet more than
just betting the game or betting the
total
but i'm against prop bets the public has
won
prop bets two times from the bookmakers
in the last 25 years that pretty much
tells me you probably
shouldn't be betting prop bets but
that's one of the things you shouldn't
bet parlays
that's insanity because of the odds and
you shouldn't bet
teasers just the name connote teasers my
god what is that
before i forget paul paul uh peps right
he works with you right yeah paulie is
my primary
integral part of that team yes is he any
is he like one of the heirs to the past
blue ribbon i'm serious
just a unusual name no i wish he was
but uh he's not he i meant to ask you
that last year
because you kept saying that and plus he
asked me he said if you'll mention that
on the air i'll send you 25
i said i'll definitely do it wow wow
well all of my guys
their last names have to do with alcohol
so well that's what working with you
will do dan i remember you from the 80s
when you were in your wild 20s easy
there danny
if you had the over under on me in my
20s would you have taken the over
over to be successful yes but to be as
successful as you've been
you got to remember i'm looking at you a
wild hellion in your 20s at cnn sports
with me
no i probably wouldn't have gone over it
very talented but
listen you would have never dreamed you
would have accomplished what you did i
think that's a safe statement and i'm
proud of you
well thank you danny and you didn't have
it given to you
you didn't inherit the past blue ribbon
the beer
franchise well todd's last name is
schlitz
so it's todd schlitz yeah and then it's
paulie pabst
uh we're not sure we changed the name at
ellis island i think it was smearing off
uh
seaton you're on last night uh first
name seaton middle name bud last name
wiser yes true story yeah so everybody
that i hired had something to do with
alcohol in their name that would explain
why your show is so popular
well we drink all day i think that's the
reason why
um hey it's great to talk to you danny
and people can see
get these tips from danny does it every
year and uh you can go to usa today and
uh he'll help you out coming up this
weekend
hope you're doing well and thanks for
reaching out danny appreciate you having
me on dan stay well and continued
success
that's uh danny sheridan you can check
out his super bowl betting tips in usa
today's special edition super bowl
55 preview